TINO TERESHKO: My
name is Tino Tereshko.
I come from Seattle,
which some people have
described in the past as the
Amsterdam of the United States.
Kind of, I guess.
So I want to, first of all,
thank everyone for being here,
and investing time in coming
here, and listening to us,
and having conversations
with us, because I
heard earlier today that people
in Amsterdam have no time.
So it's especially important for
us to recognize the investments
that you guys have made to come
here and spend time with us.
So real quick, before
we get started,
let's take a selfie, especially
the people here in the front.
On three, I want you to
raise your hands, to smile,
to clap, whatever you want.
Just make it interesting, OK?
And I'll put it
on Twitter later.
So let's do it.
1, 2, 3!
AUDIENCE: [SHOUTING] Hey!
TINO TERESHKO: That's good.
That's good.
Thank you.
So I'm here to talk
about analytics
and the various
spectrums of analytics
that are possible today with
the advancements in technology
by Google and by others.
But let's start with
a quick little story.
You probably have
seen these little cars
driving around with a 360
camera on top of them that
say Google Maps on top of them.
For the past 10
years or so, Google
has been mapping the entire
world, or as much as possible,
and externalizing that
information through Google
Maps, through Google Earth.
You're able to take a
little yellow stick figure
and put it anywhere
in the world and walk
through the neighborhoods.
I do that with
neighborhoods that I grew up
in that I haven't
been there in a while.
But the interesting
thing is this
is, of course, a massive data
collection and optimization
problem.
And it really speaks to how
heavily invested in data
Google is itself.
But the interesting thing
here is, up until recently,
up until the last four or five
years, this was just imagery,
right?
You couldn't-- and then maybe
coordinates and things like
that.
You couldn't really gain as much
insight as possible from this.
But with advancements in
AI and with advancements
in commoditization of computing
hardware and improvements
in computing power, especially
in AI machine learning,
we're able to derive further
information from this imagery.
So, for example, we can
understand that the business
has turned over, right?
There's a new business
in place there.
So we can go into
Google Maps and update
the place of business.
Or maybe this sign was
wasn't there before.
Maybe it was a two-way street,
but now you can't go this way.
So it's very important
for us to tell you
that you can't go
down this road.
So all of this, of course,
is done automatically
through our AI
learning capabilities.
And so this right here is
probably the worst kept secret
in Silicon Valley.
Google is very serious
about analytics.
It says so in our model.
It says, Google's
mission is to--
gosh-- organize all the data
that's possible in the world
and present it for bad or
good, for everyone, right?
And so Google has built
a number of technologies
that it uses internally to
organize this information.
And the premise of
Google Cloud Platform
is to be able to externalize
these technologies,
and the lessons learned,
and the power of compute
for your benefits.
So you can run alongside Google,
leveraging the same Google
investments and
technology and innovation
for yourselves as well,
which hopefully accelerates
your pace of innovation,
accelerates your iteration,
allows you to deliver faster,
better, more interesting
features to a lot
of your customers.
And the fact that Google has
been a data-driven company
for such a long time and has
built these services that
allow you to do some really
powerful things with data
analytics has made
it fairly easy
for us to become a
machine-learning company as
well.
This chart probably
needs updating.
But essentially, for the
past five or so years,
virtually every single product
and service that Google has has
become, in some ways--
and often, in many ways--
AI-driven, right?
So if you use Google Photos,
for example you can very clearly
understand the type of inference
that occurs on your content
automatically, right?
It allows you to
create stories based
on just the imagery
that's happened
and the ability to pull out
metadata about that imagery.
But, of course, you can have
too much of a good thing, right?
Going back to that example
where Google has generated
a whole lot of photos of
a whole lot of streets
around the world, and if
you need to go back in time
and process all
that information,
that is a very serious
computing power.
So you can have too much
of a good thing, right?
You can have too
much of a requirement
for AI, especially
for inference,
which is asking the model what
the model thinks is happening.
So in the last few
years, Google has
been faced with a problem,
a serious problem, right?
We have too much
demand for inference.
And we we're faced with
having to expand into dozens
and dozens of new data centers.
And if you've ever seen a
picture of a data center
that Google operates,
these are huge things.
They're bigger than
this venue here.
So it's a serious investment.
It takes time.
It's complex.
So we implemented Tensor
Processing Units--
TPUs-- and now,
we're on version 2.0.
TPUs are specially
optimized for matrix algebra
that allows you to essentially
infer results of an AI model.
Essentially, TPUs allow us to
save a whole lot of energy.
And so these are
live inside of Google
for the past several years.
They're intricate.
They're delicate.
And they're really important
to our infrastructure.
So on to a little bit
more practical terms.
When I talk to
data scientists, AI
experts, machine-learning
experts, they tend to say,
in day-to-day
activities of what they
do, some folks tell
me, well, I have
to operate an HBase
cluster, because that's
where our data is kept.
Or I have to take data from
Hadoop, run a Hive query,
create a cohort, and feed
that into a model that
lives somewhere else.
Or I have to run a
bunch of SQL queries
before I can even feed
anything into my model
to randomize samples,
and so on and so forth.
So ultimately, folks tell me
that 90% of really true AI
machine learning
workloads involve
pure data science or maybe
even data engineering, right?
So when you're faced with
complex problems like that,
it's really important to
try to minimize complexity
wherever it's not necessary.
So this is really something
interesting to keep in mind.
You can get lost in
the noise very easily.
But then, according to
Gartner, a whole lot
of projects that try to create
big data infrastructure, Data
Lakes, end up failing.
I'm not sure how accurate
that statement is,
but it's quite possibly true.
Right?
So it's very hard to do
big data in 2017, right?
Hadoop's complex.
HDFS is complex.
You need to have a
lot of expertise.
So how do you compute this?
If you want to be an AI-driven
organization, and [INAUDIBLE]
data science, but 90% of
data science projects fail,
that's kind of a daunting
proposition, right?
So I like to use
this Jenga analogy.
You guys are probably
familiar with Jenga, right?
It's basically a game where
you pile on wooden bricks
on top of each other.
And you pull out a brick from
here, and you put it on top.
So you want to think
about data infrastructure
as entirely interdependent.
Bricks on top depend on
bricks on the bottom,
and you want to have
a very clean Jenga
tower so it doesn't topple.
So at the bottom, you
could think about this as
baseline architecture.
What I mean by that is you
want to have good networking.
You want to choose a good
public cloud provider or two.
You might want to have a
really good data center, right?
You want to get that right.
And on top of that,
you want to have really
good compute, Virtual
machines, servers, containers,
and good storage.
object storage, for example.
And that aids you in developing
your good applications
and databases that power
these applications.
So in order to have
good applications,
you probably need to
have those two right.
Only then you can start thinking
about a proper data warehouse.
You can certainly
do a data warehouse
without getting all that right.
But it really helps you to have
the foundational blocks stacked
up before data warehouse.
You're probably going to
say, Tino, data warehouse
is kind of an old term.
We don't use that anymore.
We have a data lake.
Sure.
But sometimes data
lakes kind of get stale,
and they turn into data swamps.
But you drain the swamp, and
you have everything right.
And now your data
lake is so big,
you can call it
a data ocean now.
Fantastic.
Well, let's just-- you know,
let's just summarize all that,
and just use one umbrella,
data, large body of water.
I coined that.
You can ask me to use it.
But that's mine, data
large body of water.
And once you have data
large body of water set up,
then you can start thinking
about AI machine learning.
There are some exceptions
you guys saw earlier today.
And I can talk about
them some more.
But that's really
the lesson here.
And of course, it's a
Jenga tower analogy,
so if you build a
bad Jenga tower,
it's probably going
to topple, hence
the 90% of all data
lake projects fail.
That's the lesson here.
OK, so now that I've
scared you sufficiently,
let's talk about what a
modern data analytics stack
looks like.
There's probably a
whole lot of attributes
that you can identify
that you can say,
this is what has to be in a
modern data analytics stack.
So I have four that I
want to talk to you about.
The first one is separation
of storage and compute.
And that is a little
bit of a loaded term.
So let me quantify exactly
what's happening here.
Separation of
storage and compute
is really a solved problem.
It buys you so many options when
you're designing your system.
If you don't have this,
and you are operating
on a decently sized
scale, you should
look into this yesterday.
It's just the pros
and cons of having
this attribute are just
tremendous in your favor,
right?
So this is a solved problem.
Get it done.
Here's what I mean by
pure separation of storage
and compute.
It's exactly that, right?
There's a fine line between
processing and compute storage.
And that fine line
actually represents
a very powerful networking,
networking that can talk,
that allows every node
within the data center
to talk to every other node
within the same data center,
at 10 gig, all at
the same time, right?
So Google's data
centers last reported
have over a petabit of
bisectional bandwidth
per second per data center.
So that's kind of a requirement.
You have to have
good networking.
But ultimately, in
practical terms,
you can have your
various storage layers,
whether you have
BigTable, which is our--
Google's NoSQL database.
You can have BigQuery storage,
which is our data warehousing
data lake storage.
Or you can have Object Store,
where you keep your cat videos.
And you can have
Google Cloud Dataflow,
for example, which is our
batch and stream processing
unified programming
model and engine,
access all of those,
regardless of where they live.
Or potentially, you
can have BigQuery SQL,
which is standard, run SQL
queries on all of those--
not cat videos, but just
ignore that for a second.
And you can have your
own Hadoop and Spark
clusters run on top of
that information as well.
So I'm not discounting
the significance
that Hadoop and Spark have
in today's environment.
The momentum behind these
projects is phenomenal, right?
So we have Google
Cloud Dataproc,
which is our fully
managed Spark,
Hadoop and Flink service.
The awesome thing
about our service
specifically is that you can get
clusters very, very quickly--
90 seconds.
Hopefully you guys
see that over there.
90 seconds is 99th
percentile from the moment
you push the button to the
moment your cluster is live,
ready to use.
That's very fast,
especially within--
you know, if you're coming from
your own on-premise private
data center space,
the typical numbers
that I hear involve six to nine
months, sometimes even longer.
So 90 seconds is just a
phenomenal change, right?
It enables so many options.
And, of course, we have
pay per minute, right?
So you can shut this thing
down after 20 minutes
if you'd like to.
You save the results
into storage.
That's where the state is.
And because we have fully
[? femoral ?] preemptible VMs--
which, kind of disappear
every once in awhile
in exchange for 80%
off of list price.
So you can have very
quick Hadoop clusters
that you can shut down
whenever you want,
because you pay by the
minute, and you actually
don't pay a whole lot for it.
And so the idea is that
Hadoop doesn't really
keep a lot of state.
Unless it's intermediate state,
state lives in storage, right?
Initial state and output lives
in any of these storage pieces.
The other really big point here
is that data silos are bad.
You're playing the
game of telephone
with data when
you're moving data
around needlessly,
ultimately, you'll
end up with multiple
copies of data.
And a funny thing happens.
When two data scientists
try to get the same answers
to the same problem
using the same data,
if that data lives
in other places,
they'll come up with
different results.
I'm still not sure
how that happens.
But data silos are
bad, amd separation
of storage and compute allows
you not to deal with that.
So here's another different
analogy that I can use.
Well, first, of all, I
apologize, especially
to the CXOs.
This is-- you know,
we don't think of you
that poorly from
these stick figures.
But ultimately, this is what
your potential organization
could look like.
Even at a startup, you can
have this type of delineation.
And you can have
your various bits
of data living inside of the
query, all the way from very,
very raw data that comes
from application databases
and services, to data that's
potentially sensitive that you
don't necessarily want to have
floating around everywhere,
to real-time
dashboards, things that
tell you the state
of your business,
and all the way to data
that you can potentially
want to externalize
from your infrastructure
to your third parties,
to clients, because they
find use in that.
So they all have
different roles here.
And the nice thing about
our separation of storage
and compute, just like with
Google Docs, or Google Sheets,
where you can, in [? Place ?]
share information and share
collateral with other folks
within your organizations
outside, you can do the same
thing with our data lake--
data body of water--
services.
So IT and Ops could potentially
have the overreaching role
of this organization.
They want to own
every single data set.
They want to administer that.
That's fine.
And so in our Access
Controls, they say,
I'm the owner and everything,
just like in Google Docs.
But the data engineers
may only need
to have your access
to the really raw data
sets, the really
important data sets,
because you don't
want to mess that up.
But then, they're the ones
that are creating dashboards.
They're the ones that are
creating these data sets.
And so they have
editor access to that.
And, of course, the
obvious follows.
Right?
Your executives get a real-time
dashboard in View mode,
and you can even
share in [? Place ?]
without having an FTB server.
In [? Place, ?] you can share
your data with third parties,
so they can run SQL
analytics in real time
without having to do a whole
lot of work on top of your data.
So it's pretty awesome.
And I've showed this already.
Data silos are bad.
It's a relic of
old architectures--
tried to avoid that ourselves.
So the second aspect of modern
analytics I want to talk about
is this concept of serverless.
And of course, you've heard
of the various terms that--
or the various contacts within
which server is mentioned.
So the most confined
definition of serverless is--
it's actually Cloud Functions,
tiny little pieces of code
that execute one at a time.
But the industry has been
extending this buzzword further
into identifying
some things that
have a very high
level of abstraction,
some things that
are fully managed,
that essentially allow you
to use a [? femoral, ?]
very, very scalable
piece of compute,
and only pay for the
resources that you use.
So our serverless analytics
kind of central piece
here is BigQuery.
Actually, I was on the
BigQuery team before recently,
and it's an amazing product.
If you haven't used it, you
should definitely look into it.
BigQuery is our fully managed
analytics data warehouse.
It does have separation
of storage and compute.
It has a very, very
powerful storage engine
that's self-optimized,
that self-heals.
It tries to understand how
you're using the storage
and burns a whole
lot of CPU and RAM
to optimize the storage
for your workload.
It does that on your behalf.
So it's kind of
opinionated in that regard.
And of course, that
storage component
allows you to share data within
your organization or outside
of the organization
in very elegant ways
without having to
copy that data around.
On the other side, BigQuery
has a compute engine.
It's basically Dremel.
And Dremel-- you can
go read the paper
that's published by Google.
Dremel executes SQL
queries in real time,
very fast analytical workloads.
And BigQuery has an incredibly
high level of abstraction.
You never have to
touch hardware.
You never have to define
storage or compute,
or really, not a lot
of configuration there.
And that's on
purpose, because we
want you to focus on
what's important to you.
So let's take a look at
what BigQuery looks like,
if you haven't seen it.
So this is the
BigQuery UI, which
is one of the many ways you
can interact with BigQuery.
And at first, it doesn't
really look all that exciting.
It kind of looks aged a
little bit, kind of like Gmail
from 2004.
But just like Gmail from
2004, when you had what?
A gigabyte inbox right away?
When you were yelling
at your grandma
when she sent you a 30-megabyte
video because your inbox
would explode, and now
you get a gigabyte.
That's amazing.
And so just like Gmail in 2004
hides a whole lot of complexity
and a whole lot of power
underneath the hood
and a simple UI, BigQuery
does the exact same thing.
So let me show you.
So this is-- right
here, BigQuery petabyte
is a data set, kind of like
a database that BigQuery has.
And I'm going to click
on this sales partition
table here, which is a
table that we made up.
It's not real data.
We did it for the
purposes of demonstrating
the power of BigQuery.
So there's nothing
super special about it.
I'm going to look at the
schema here of this table.
What you see here that's
really, really interesting--
so it's typical, order
execution, when it happens,
how much.
But here we have actually
nested structures,
like we have an array
inside of the table.
It's pretty awesome.
So you can have an array of
an array, JSON-like structures
that are very, very
complicated, or very simple.
But it kind of allows you to
have interesting relationships
with your data here.
So that's a schema.
If I'm going to click on
what the table looks like,
you'll see here that
the table size is
a little bit over a petabyte.
It's a decently sized table.
And that looks like
a trillion rows,
a trillion rows in this table.
So the most sensible thing
to do with this table
is to try and query it live.
So I'm going to--
I have this saved query here.
So I just push the big red
button that said, Wrong Query.
Oh, no!
I has the cache turned on.
So we're going to not cheat.
We're not going to have cache.
But if you look at this
query, the only thing
that I'm doing here
to really cheat
is that this petabyte table
has three years worth of data.
We're only doing-- we're only
calling one month of partition.
But otherwise, it's querying
a whole lot of data.
And it's got a join.
It's got a big old
regular expression.
It's got a window
function, everything
you can possibly imagine
in a typical query, right?
Mixed bag-- oh!
Looks like we've finished
this in, you know,
16 and 1/2 seconds.
So this table didn't
have anything special.
There's no keys.
There's no indexes.
We didn't do any
optimizations, really,
outside of what the
BigQuery service itself
provides in terms of
automation and optimization.
All we did was load
that data into BigQuery.
So that's the demo here.
So let's talk about
what exactly happened.
So I know--
I've ran this query before,
so I know how much resource
it takes to execute this
query in under 20 seconds.
So it's about 3,000 cores.
So you could potentially
take that data set,
and if you have 3,000
cores lying around,
you'd deploy that,
assuming you have
similar software to BigQuery,
you can execute that.
You can run your own demo
of that, if you'd like.
And so that's really
what we did right
we rented 3,000
cores from Google
for the length of the job.
So let's think about this
in virtual machine terms.
Virtual machines take
minutes to start.
You get per hour billing,
maybe per minute, maybe.
And virtual machines-- it's
hard to get 3,000 cores very
quickly.
Right?
So what BigQuery
allows you to do
is to go from 0 to 3,000
for only 16 seconds--
20 seconds-- and you
get the equivalent
of only paying for
what you consume.
Now, the asterisk
here is that BigQuery
charges not per second.
It charges for the
amount of data processed.
But that's a great
proxy to think
about when you're
trying to relate this
to virtual machines.
But that's all fine and dandy.
The really key
benefit of serverless
is that you get a
whole lot of power
for very short periods of time.
And you don't even care
that that's happening.
All you care about
is you have data,
you wrote a
interesting SQL query,
and you push the big
red button, and you
want to get the results.
That's what you care about.
Like, sometimes you might
want to geek out and think
about that.
But ultimately, this
is where you live.
And that's the benefit
of serverless, really.
So that's a lot of power,
very short bits of time.
And of course, if you
want to extend that
to TensorFlow and machine
learning technologies,
our fully managed cloud
machine learning engine service
allows you to do the exact same
things on top of TPUs and GPUs.
So you can rent--
ultimately, you can rent
lots and lots of resources
for short periods of
time without having
to worry to stand
up those resources,
manage those resources
in order for you
to train your TensorFlow models.
And once the model
is complete, you
can take that into
your own environment.
You can take that into
Google Cloud platform
and deploy it, or even on your
mobile devices, for example.
And you might have seen
this already in other talks.
But the one exception to
that whole Jenga analogy
that I've used
earlier is that there
has been a whole
lot of research done
by Google and by
other technologies
to train models on
large bits of data.
Google has a good
amount of data, right?
So we've taken our
investments in technologies,
and we've externalized them
through simple APIs, rest APIs.
So any developer can use
them, implement them inside
of your application.
Now you have an
AI-driven application.
And you can certainly get
that next round of funding,
if you say AI in your name.
So the third aspect I want
to talk about is real time.
Real time analytics is
also a solved problem.
There are certainly
use cases where
you can have batched
nightly analytics hourly.
But you have a very easy path
to getting analytics on data
as it occurs.
And this is a very typical path
that our organizations take.
Now, Spotify has blogged
about this quite extensively,
and other companies, of course.
"New York Times" is an avid
user of this right here.
It's a very high
levels of abstraction
across three services that
allow you to move data
from the moment it occurs in
your application, to the moment
that you have
precomputed analytics.
You have a dashboard you're
trying to develop here.
And to the moment that you
want to have real-time access
to SQL, to your analyst, your
data scientist who has data--
all of that is built. You
just have to implement it.
And it's a very popular
way of doing things today.
The last thing I want
to talk about is ETL.
I have to do ETL sometimes,
and I don't really
find that necessarily
too enjoyable.
It's a means to an end.
There is no glory in it.
So ETL should be easy.
We should just get that
in as quickly as possible,
have it as clean as possible,
and focus on value again.
So I'm going to give you a quick
demo of what I'm talking about.
So I have this dataset here
called [? Citibank ?] Data.
It's just a bunch of rows.
I actually took BigQuery's
public data sets,
and I exported
them for this demo.
So just a bunch of information.
And I ran this--
I'm going to run
this BigQuery job.
It's going to take this--
oh, I need to update my CLI.
I need to-- basically,
I'm taking that data--
and hopefully, the
Internet holds up--
and I'm going to load it into
BigQuery for a quick analysis.
Wait a minute.
We've got an error.
Oh, no.
No, I'm kidding.
I made that--
So it looks like the error
says, at position 751,
there is closed
double quotes that
have something inside of them.
All right, well,
I'm going to go to--
let's go to that line.
This is the line that
it's talking about.
Hmm.
Oh, I see what it is.
So I have this quotation
here, and inside of it
is an escape character
that BigQuery
doesn't like for some reason.
And of course, there
is an RFC on it
that says, for comma
delimited values,
you can only escape
quotes with other quotes.
And BigQuery is very pedantic.
It likes RFCs.
So it rejects your data.
So what do we do?
Well, we have this other
tool called Dataprep
that you can leverage today.
And I'm going to create a
job inside of Dataflow that
will hopefully recognize
that information.
So I'm going to go ahead and go
through the flow of importing
that file inside of Dataprep.
There it is.
It's going to load that file
in, or at least some part of it,
and then it's going to run
some statistical analysis
to understand what
exactly is going on.
It's going to try to understand
what the data looks like--
did I do that?
Yep.
It's going to try to understand
what the data looks like,
if there are outliers,
if there are errors,
if it's going to try to
parse this information,
and so on and so forth.
So it looks like it created
this thing for me here.
And this is basically
an ETL job, right?
I have the file, and it's
going to create a job.
And this is the recipe
that it's going to execute,
which is very simple.
You can certainly make
that more complex.
So we're going to
look at the data
and see exactly
what happens here.
Now we wait.
But the idea here,
again, is that the--
wow, it's taking really slow.
I did not have enough content
prepared to fill this time.
But ultimately, what
is going to happen
is it's going to take that
bad row that I threw in there,
and it's going to
recognize that row.
And it's going to say,
hey, that is actually
an escape character.
It's not conforming to an RFC.
But we definitely think
it's an escape character.
So-- wow-- live demos
don't always work, I guess.
So let's forget about that.
You're just going to have
to take my word for it.
So with a tool like Dataprep,
you have one click ETL.
You can take ugly data
that's, you know--
if it works.
You can take ugly data
that doesn't conform
to any standards,
and you want to-- you
don't want to write Python
code or anything like that.
You just want it in one
place for you to analyze.
So Dataprep is a
fantastic tool for that.
Under the hood,
Dataprep actually
creates Apache Beam pipelines.
It creates these recipes that
turn to Apache Beam pipelines,
and then executes them on
top of Google Cloud Dataflow.
So you are familiar
with that technology.
This is actually a pretty
cool way of doing things.
So Dataprep is awesome.
So to very quickly
summarize, the practice
of data architecture
or data infrastructure
is moving very, very quickly.
But there are
pillars that emerge
that become very obvious
wins very, very quickly.
And these pillars can
simplify your life.
And this is kind of like, can
I have things simpler, cheaper,
and faster?
Yes.
And this is because the
architectures fundamentally
change.
You can save money and get more.
That's the lesson here.
So that's really the four
things that I've identified.
I'm sure you can
find many, many more.
I'm going to close this
on saying that, you know,
the whole concept
of serverless--
the idea here, again,
is that we want
to provide the highest level
of abstraction possible.
We want to automate all the
noise, all the tinkering,
all the things that are not
really that important to you.
You don't want to tinker.
Abstract that away,
automate of that away,
and give you a surface that
allows you to create value.
So instead of doing very
little value and a whole lot
of tinkering, we want to flip
that equation on its head.
So we want to give
you the ability
to create a lot of value
in very little tinkering.
And that's what
serverless means.
So I thank you very much.
But before we finish, I'm
going to have Geoffrey
and Constantijn come on stage.
We're going to have just
a quick little fireside
chat where we can take
questions from each other
and from the audience as well.
Geoffrey comes from RTL,
and his organization
implemented some interesting
analytics workloads
on top of Google.
And Constantijn is from
a services partner that
helped Geoffrey implement this.
Please.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks for coming, guys.
Geoffrey, can you tell me
more about your organization?
GEOFFREY VAN MEER: RTL, yeah.
RTL is not only a TV broadcast.
So it's a multimedia company.
So we have also a lot
of digital assets.
Nobody knows, but RTL Group is
the largest content uploader
on YouTube in Europe.
And we work a lot with
the Google products,
also in ESL's domain,
in [INAUDIBLE] domain,
and also, in the
big data domain.
TINO TERESHKO: So when it
comes to big data specifically,
it's a big data session.
What have you guys done?
What did you implement?
GEOFFREY VAN MEER: We store
the data in the Google storage.
Contstantijn helped
us with building the--
we have a Spark platform,
so he built the platform
based on Dataproc.
And we have BigQuery
on top of that.
So it's in our
distribution of products
that we have implemented.
And it helps us in
all various ways.
It's very transparent.
It's easy to use the setup.
I can go to my
business stakeholder
and tell him exactly which
query takes that much long.
It costs me so much euro.
If you want to have
it faster, no problem.
I can put more machines on.
And you can have it faster.
That's the decision,
up to the business.
That makes it
really transparent.
We're all really,
really powerful.
TINO TERESHKO: So it
sounds like your business,
with the help of
Google Cloud Platform,
was really enabled to perform
better analytics and more data.
Can you talk about it more?
GEOFFREY VAN MEER: Yeah.
What I like about it is that
you bring the decision back
to the business.
If they want to have it
faster, you can have it.
So it's of their decision.
If you have it within 15
minutes, I don't mind.
We'll make it short
in 15 minutes.
It costs a little bit more,
but it's their decision.
It's not an IT issue.
It's a business decision.
That's what I like.
TINO TERESHKO: That's fantastic.
And so, I'm aware that you guys
are leveraging Google BigQuery.
Can you talk more about
this particular piece
of our infrastructure?
GEOFFREY VAN MEER: Yeah.
BigQuery helps us a lot in our
grow intelligence maturity.
So, like every
company, we have a set
of reports that helps
you by measuring
how many customers you
have, how many revenue
you have, and blah, blah, blah.
But then it happens
that customers
go away, cancel
their subscription,
or the revenue drops down.
So reports tell you
about what's happening.
And then you want answers
on why people left,
why cancel their subscription?
Then you have to
go into the data.
And it helps business people
to query large data sets,
finding answers on
why people left.
What was the behavior
before they left?
So it empowers, again,
business people, not
a group of data scientists.
They can create.
They can do a lot.
Now, business people, you
give access to large data
sets and finding
answers on the problems
you see over a rise
in your reports.
Very powerful.
TINO TERESHKO: And
I wish-- you know,
I wish big data buzzword was
actually called holistic data,
because it allows you to
store very raw information
about what's going on
with your applications,
how your users are interacting
with your application.
So then further
down the line, you
can have your analysts
understand specifically
what the behaviors were and
why they left your platform.
GEOFFREY VAN MEER: Yeah.
And when you have
those answers, then you
can ask data scientists to
make predictive modeling.
But it's the step in between
that you want to have a broader
audience in your company, people
in the business-- marketeers,
salespeople== have also
access to launch data sets.
And it's really important
to make that grow also
to AI and machine learning.
TINO TERESHKO: Yeah.
Which leads me to
my next question.
What's your take on
AI machine learning?
What are your plans, and
what are the opportunities
within your organization?
GEOFFREY VAN MEER: We are
a total video company,
so we have a lot of
content, video content.
That's what I like about RTL.
So we analyze the
content, the video,
because it tells me about
the quality of the content.
So we have a lot of content that
must help me, but what is the--
I want to quantify the
quality of the content.
So I use also the video APIs.
But we also install
TensorFlow and Keras
to have a better understanding
of what's happening on screen.
And that generates
a lot of metadata,
tags, labels that helps me
also in my recommendation.
So I can prove
that a little more.
I need to have a
better understanding
of the quality of content.
TINO TERESHKO: We
haven't forgotten
about you, Constantijn.
So Constantijn was
one of the job men
that did a whole lot of the
heavy lifting on this project.
Can you tell us more
about what you've done?
CONSTANTIJN VISINESCU: Yep.
When I started with the
project, they already
were using Hadoop and Spark.
But they had their
own on-prem cluster
with a fixed amount of machines.
So that was also--
for starters, it
was very expensive,
because it was always on 24/7.
And that meant it was--
either it was not big enough,
because they wanted their data
now, or it was standing around
costing money doing nothing.
And it also meant
there was one cluster.
So if two people
at the same time
wanted to do something
with the data,
they had to wait for each other.
And, yeah, there were multiple
data scientists, multiple data
engineers, and also,
multiple data analysts.
And, yeah, if one of them
is using the cluster,
the others are not doing
anything useful for RTL.
And at the same
time, I also noticed
that keeping your own Hadoop
and Spark cluster up and running
can be quite labor intensive.
And, yeah, RTL would much
rather spend that effort
doing useful business things,
than running after their Hadoop
Spark cluster.
So I suggested we
could move them over
to Dataproc for starters.
And yeah-- and then
they could stop
worrying about maintaining
them, and at the same time,
like the example showed, if you
want a 100-node cluster right
now, that's fine.
And if your job only
takes 10 minutes,
then you'd throw it away.
If there's three people
that want to do something
at the same time, you
spin up three clusters,
and then you throw
away three clusters.
So you can just keep working.
And, like Tino said
also in the slide,
if you separate the
data from your compute,
three people want to
work at the same--
want to work on the same
data set, that's also fine,
because you're not tied to get
one data set that lives over
in that one cluster.
TINO TERESHKO: How long
did your project take?
CONSTANTIJN VISINESCU: The whole
project was several months.
But it also included mostly
understanding the data.
One of the nice things
about using Google Cloud
was that setting up the
infrastructure basically
took me 15 minutes, because
I've done it before.
But i can just click--
I want a cluster, I
uploaded their data to--
I uploaded their data to Google
Cloud [? desk ?] set, and one
of their existing Spark
jobs that they were already
running on Premise.
And within 15 minutes, I
had working infrastructure.
And I could start spending
the rest of the time actually
analyzing the data and
figuring out what to do with it
rather than babysitting
the infrastructure.
TINO TERESHKO: So
going forward, what
would be your
recommendation, if you
were going to implement
this type of infrastructure
in the future?
CONSTANTIJN VISINESCU: Well,
if you already have Spark,
you can just take your existing
Spark jobs that usually
work on HDFS and put your
data in Google Storage,
so you get the
date of separation.
Cloud Dataproc comes with
integration for Google storage,
basically the same
way you use HDFS.
So you can just put your
data in Google storage,
take your existing job,
and change the output
from HDFS to Google
storage and just run it.
And that's a great first step.
TINO TERESHKO: Any other
comments either one of you
would like to share
about the project?
GEOFFREY VAN MEER: In a
[? SQL ?] sense, it's easy--
relatively easy-- to manage.
So you can allocate your time
more on business problems.
So the maintenance
is relatively easy.
It's very transparent.
And what I also
like is that each--
as you explained,
data scientists come
to the office in the morning,
they spin up at the cluster,
and here they go.
So they're not interfering
with each other.
And they use all the
same-- the old cluster,
all the applications on there,
so they can play around.
And today, data starts, I
want a cluster of 10 machines.
And tomorrow, I'll do a
different type of algorithm,
and I'll spin up a cluster
of 50 machines after them.
And I know exactly, as a
manager, who was using what.
So I can also say, you
burned too much, lower down,
or spin up.
TINO TERESHKO: Fantastic.
Constantijn?
CONSTANTIJN VISINESCU:
Yeah, that's--
like Geoffrey said, that really
helped their data scientists.
And it also helped
later on the project,
because the original
project used
Spark to put their
data into an existing--
pre-process their data
into a normal SQL database.
But that means that
sometimes that, when
some of the data engineers are
busy, I literally told them--
heard them tell one of
the data analysts, like,
can you please not do your work
until 2:00 in the afternoon,
because I'm busy
using the database?
And, yeah, like, I understand
from a technical's perspective,
because, the data
engineer was just
keeping the database very busy.
But you don't want that.
So instead of putting the
data into a normal database,
we put the data in
BigQuery, as you saw.
And RTL has lots
of data because,
like Geoffrey said,
there's a large multimedia
presence on the
Internet from RTL,
not just the RTL label,
but multiple labels.
And that literally generates
billions of data points.
And I can just put
those into BigQuery.
I don't even have to
aggregate them anymore.
So before, all the
data was aggregated,
and you could only get the
reports that the aggregation
was specifically made for.
And now all the data
is just in there.
And yeah, there are some
premade aggregations
to make things
easier on the users.
But it's basically
do whatever you want.
And again, because
it's serverless,
as long as you don't request
more compute power than Google
has, like, you don't make Google
crash, then they can go nuts.
TINO TERESHKO: Fantastic.
[LAUGHTER]
And we challenge you to do that.
So we have a few minutes to take
questions from the audience.
So please raise your
hand, and there will
be a microphone coming around.
Please, right here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
What's the difference
between BigQuery and Spanner?
TINO TERESHKO:
Fantastic question.
So BigQuery and Spanner are
used extensively internally
at Google and by our clients.
The easiest way to think
about it is BigQuery
is great for
analytics, whereas, you
know, things like aggregating
lots of information.
And Spanner is a fantastic
tool to create an application
or to have an
operational database.
They go hand in hand together.
Yeah.
And they actually both speak
the same standard SQL language.
Any other questions?
Please.
CONSTANTIJN VISINESCU: You have
another question over there.
TINO TERESHKO: Yeah.
GEOFFREY VAN MEER: Over there.
AUDIENCE: Your 20 second
query of what was it?
3,000 nodes?
What's the money being spent?
TINO TERESHKO: That's
a great question.
So that particular query
cost about $10 to run.
So the query has two pricing
models, specifically.
One is paper job, as I did.
And for folks who are
at a larger scale, who
have specific use cases, you
can pay a flat monthly fee
that includes all your queries.
Good question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Like a lot of BI
departments, in our company,
we're a bit of a bottleneck when
it comes to data preparation.
So Dataprep looks cool, because
we can put that out there.
How difficult would
it be to productionize
the output of Dataprep?
TINO TERESHKO: That's
a good question.
In terms of productionize, you
want to put this into a place
where analysts can work on it.
AUDIENCE: Sure, selected
analysts might get 20 files.
They do their thing.
And then we've got
6,000 files that we
need to run through
a nightly process.
And so that kind of
production, I think--
TINO TERESHKO: Yeah, that is
an intrinsic-- that's exactly
the use case for Dataprep.
So it's an intrinsic
quality of that service.
CONSTANTIJN VISINESCU:
Actually, we
had to do pretty much the
exact same thing at RTL.
One of the nice
things about BigQuery
is that, next to
its native custom
drivers that are
really fast, it also
has an existing ODBC driver.
And it speaks standard ANSI SQL.
So it can talk with anything
that can talk SQL over ODBC.
And that is basically--
anything that calls itself
a data analytics tool
can talk with it.
So at RTL, the main tool
for business intelligence
is Business Objects.
And I just set up an ODBC query.
And within a couple
days, Business Objects
could talk the
BigQuery and no one
would notice the difference.
And there's also
several other tools
with RTL, just their
own departments using
their own tools.
And as long as they can talk
ODBC with standard ANSI SQL,
then it just works.
TINO TERESHKO: We're
essentially out of time,
but we'll take one final
question, right there.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
taking my question.
So, a lot of analytic projects
live in an IT landscape, not
just a Google landscape.
Can you say something about
how to roll out into production
both code and infrastructure?
And how do you see integration
with existing, let's say,
applications and
deployment pipeline?
So I'm thinking, so how do
you use this stuff with Git?
How do you roll all that stuff?
TINO TERESHKO: Yeah.
CONSTANTIJN VISINESCU:
At RTL, we had--
our pipelines were in code.
There's two out there
called the Air Flow
and that's also from Apache.
And that allows you to model
all your data pipelines as code.
So there's jobs in there
like, spin up a cluster,
run these Spark jobs,
spin down the cluster,
and take the output
from that Spark job
and put it into BigQuery.
That's all code.
And that code lives
in a Git repository.
And there's a Jenkins on
top of that Git repository.
So if I commit to master,
Jenkins runs the tests.
If the tests look
good, it automatically
puts it to the
accept environment.
And if I hit the button, the
same code goes to production.
TINO TERESHKO: The
value of ecosystem
that creates orchestration
and monitoring, things
like that can't be understated.
So Google specifically
invested in partnerships
and in supporting open source
technologies like Airflow
that we've extended
into our services.
And if there are
technologies that
are compelling that
we don't know about,
we want to know
about them as well.
Thank you, folks.
I think this is-- we
have run out of time.
But thanks for your time.
Great.
And thank you as well.
[APPLAUSE]